dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here have a
look and marvel at this learning-based
assembler robot that is able to put
together simple contraptions since this
is a neural network based learning
method it needs to be trained to be able
to do this so how is it trained normally
to train such an algorithm we would have
to show it a lot of pairs of the same
contraption and tell it that this is
what it looks like when it's
disassembled and what you see here is
the same thing assembled if we did this
this method would be called supervised
learning this would be very
time-consuming and potentially expensive
as it would require the presence of a
human as well a more convenient way
would be to go for unsupervised learning
where we just chuck a lot of things on
the table and say well robot you figure
it out however this would be very
inefficient if at all possible because
we would have to provide it many many
contraptions that wouldn't fit on the
table but this paper went for none of
these solutions as they opted for a
really smart self supervised technique
so what does that mean well first we
give the robot an assembled contraption
and ask it to disassemble it and therein
lies the really cool idea because
disassembling it is easier and by
rewinding the process it also gets to
know how to assemble it later and the
training process takes place by
assembling disassembling and doing it
over and over again several hundred
times per object isn't this amazing
love it however what is the point of all
this instead we could just add explicit
instructions to a non learning based
robot to assemble the objects why not
just do that
and the answer lies in one of the most
important aspects within machine
learning generalization if we program a
robot to be able to assemble one thing
it will be able to do exactly that
assemble one thing and whenever we have
a new contraption on our hands
we need to reprogram it however with
this technique after the learning
process took place we will be able to
give it anew previously unseen object
it will have a chance to assemble it
this requires intelligence to perform so
how good is it a generalization well get
this the paper reports that when showing
it new objects it was able to
successfully assemble new previously
I've seen contraptions 86% of the time
incredible so what about the limitations
this technique works on a 2d planar
surface for instance this table and
while it is able to insert most of these
parts vertically it does not deal well
with more complex assemblies that
require inserting screws and pegs in a
45 degree angle as we always say two
more papers down the line and this will
likely be improved significantly if you
have ever bought a new bed or a cupboard
and said well it just looks like a block
how hard can it be to assemble wait does
this thing have more than a hundred
screws and pegs
I wonder why and then four and a half
hours later you find out yourself
I hope techniques like these will help
us save time by enabling us to buy many
of these contraptions preassembled and
it can be used for much much more what a
time to be alive this episode has been
supported by lamda if you are a
researcher or a startup looking for
cheap GPU compute to run these
algorithms check out lamda GPU cloud
I've talked about lambdas GPU
workstations in other videos and I'm
happy to tell you that they are offering
GPU cloud services as well the lambda
GPU cloud can train imagenet to 93%
accuracy for less than $19 lambdas
web-based IDE
lets you easily access your instance
right in your browser and finally hold
on to your papers because the lambda GPU
cloud costs less than half of AWS and
aja make sure to go to lambda labs comm
slash papers and sign up for one of
their amazing GPU instances today our
thanks to lambda for helping us make
better videos for you thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time